>> AFTER DECADES OF FLAT-OUT
LYING, THE DEFENSE
ESTABLISHMENT IS FINDING
ADMITTING SOME OF WHAT IT
KNOWS ABOUT U.F.O.s.
THE NAVY ADMITTED THAT THE
PILOTS IDENTIFIED UNIDENTIFIED
AIRCRAFT -- PILOTS COME IN
CONTACT WITH UNIDENTIFIED
AIRCRAFT OFTEN.
THEY ARE SEEING THINGS IN THE
SKY THEY CAN'T ACCOUNT FOR,
AND DOING THINGS THEY CANNOT
UNDERSTAND.
SHOULD WE BE WORRIED?
CONGRESSMAN MARK WALKER IS A
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING NORTH
CAROLINA.
HE JUST SENT A NAVY TO THE
SECRETARY OF THE NAVY WILL
SPENCER ABOUT THE U.F.O.
INVESTIGATION.
WE SPOKE TO THE CONGRESSMAN.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT HE SAID.
SHOULD WE BE WORRIED ABOUT
THIS?
>> WELL, WE ARE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
AS THE RANKING MEMBER OF
TERRORISM AND
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE, WE HAVE
QUESTIONS.
IT COMES DOWN TO SOME OF THE
NEW INFRARED RADAR SYSTEMS ON
THE NEW JETS.
THEY ARE DETECTING THINGS.
WE CALL THEM UNIDENTIFIED
AERIAL THREATS.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE LOOK AT.
U.A.T. IS WHAT WE CALL THEM.
WE ARE TAKING A LOOK AT THIS.
>> Tucker: THIS IS GOING ON
FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE IS A LOT OF DATA THE
GOVERNMENT STORED ABOUT THIS.
MOST OF IT IS STILL CLASSIFIED
THERE.
MUST BE THEORIES WHAT THE
OBJECTS ARE AND WHAT THE
AIRCRAFTS ARE.
WHAT IS THE MOST PLAUSIBLE
THEORY, DO YOU THINK?
>> WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE,
OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT WE DO KNOW AND THE
QUESTION WE WANT TO GO TO IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT IS A
DEFENSE MECHANISM FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY?
CHINA LOOKING AT THE HYPER
SONIC MISSILES.
TO BREAK IT DOWN TO OUR
LANGUAGE IT WILL GET FROM D.C.
TO L.A. IN NINE MINUTES.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT NUCLEAR
WARHEADS CAN BE ATTACHED TO
THOSE.
IS IT SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
OR IS IT SOMETHING MORE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
SOMETHING TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE WRITTEN
SECRETARY SPENCER OF THE NAVY.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY
INDICATION THAT YOU ARE AWARE
OF THAT THESE SIGHTINGS ARE
FOREIGN AIRCRAFT, RUSSIAN OR
CHINESE AIRCRAFT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT.
WE DO KNOW SOMETHING IS
TRAVELING AT THAT SPEED OF
WHAT WE CALL HYPERSONIC NOW.
MACH 4 OR 5.
NOT TO GET TOO TECHNICAL.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE WANT TO
KNOW.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT ANOTHER
DEFENSE SYSTEM IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY IS MORE ADVANCED?
OR IS IT SOMETHING ELSE?
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO SPOOK
PEOPLE OUT.
BUT THE A.A.T.I.P., WHICH
BASICALLY IS A PROGRAM THAT
THE GOVERNMENT MONITORS THIS
WAS TO CLOSE DOWN IN 2017.
SO PART OF MY QUESTION,
TUCKER, IS IT REALLY CLOSED
DOWN?
ARE WE STILL SPENDING
RESOURCES?
OR IS THERE MORE DOCUMENTATION
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS STILL
BEING ABLE TO FILE SOMEWHERE?
THAT IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
KNOW.
EVEN IF IT'S JUST FOR THE
DEFENSE PURPOSES ALONE.
>> Tucker: WE SPOKE TO A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE WHO HAS
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE WHO SAID
THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
WRECKAGE FROM ONE OF THESE
AIRCRAFT.
DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW BUT THAT IS
ONE OF THE FOUR QUESTIONS THAT
WE ARE ASKING.
IS THERE EVIDENCE BEING HELD
SOMEWHERE?
NOT TO GET TOO SPOOKY ONCE
AGAIN.
IF THERE IS EVIDENCE, I
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY IN MY
POSITION AS THE RANKING MEMBER
OF TERRORISM AND
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE, WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
THOSE ARE ALL LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS.
>> I BELIEVE SO.
>> Tucker: I GRATEFUL YOU